Vision Pro is here we just went and
picked up three of them and unlike the
early reviewers we can actually be
brutally honest so guys get behind the
cameras and let's dig in now Ben
actually tried us on for fitment but I
actually refused that whole service just
to make sure I can give you guys my
genuine First Impressions and I have to
say this box is massive you're
definitely paying for a lot of packaging
and look at this thing we got the BR
cover on the front like people were
saying online and I have to say let's
pick this thing up okay that is weird um
the actual headset itself is smaller
than I imagined now this thing is such
high quality man look at that awesome I
can't believe I'm seeing this thing in
person wow okay oh my
goodness okay B Reach Out And Touch This
just grab your hand feel this feel how
soft that is wow oh my goodness gracious
and these speakers feel great we're
going to give you guys our feedback on
that let's go ahead and take this little
cover off man even this thing is high
quality this thing is Tiny compared to
my quest and look at these vents for
airflow in the fans it's massive and the
crazy thing is online they try to hide
all these cameras but you can clearly
see all of those cameras and sensors and
this band I cannot get over this apple
sure does love their magnets that is
really cool and they don't tell you how
much of a fingerprint magnet this is but
good thing that they give you that
polishing cloth and this thing is packed
full of documentation little packages
the other band let me quickly wipe that
off well my magnet's coming off here and
here is the battery and my goodness this
thing is heavy it's a a lot bigger than
I expected good thing I bought the
little carrying case thing but no wonder
they didn't put this into the actual
headset itself the headset actually
feels lighter than I expected and you
have to remember that we have an M2 Chip
plus the R1 chip not a little Android
chip which is why this puts out 78 Watts
we have 6 amps 13 volts and it's 36 wat
hour so reviewers are wrong saying it's
a 3,000 milliamp hour pack now I didn't
buy Apple $200 case because it's heavy
and big and you wouldn't believe how
much I got this case for I'll link it
down below let's go ahead and lock this
in and first time
ever let's slide this thing on Wow how
is it well I got to tighten up this
little side right here I mean that is an
ingenious system you literally twist
this you get a nice lock honestly at
least at the start it does not feel
extremely heavy and all the padding is
So Soft that it makes it feel much nicer
than my quest look like you have ski
goggles man does it look cool yeah
saying press and hold I'm seeing some
already it's trying to adjust Apple logo
oh but I see you yeah oh my
goodness okay I have to say something
uhhuh this does not look like complete
reality no it does not what's it look
like then okay it looks like an iPhone
recording okay is that good or bad
um I expected the pass through to look
better oh man um well way better than
the quest but still when you watch the
videos online it looks insane here this
is clearly did you see me move I saw you
move I see a lot of noise in that dark
corner a lot of noise okay it's talking
to me and that sound sounds really good
it's telling me to get my iPhone out and
look at this setup Vision Pro all right
this is cool it's showing me where to
look like if you're setting up a Apple
watch dang oh my goodness how is it okay
it dimmed everything it's showing me a
video and the quality looks insane it
looks like I'm looking at like a 4K
display or maybe better than a 4K 32in
display wow it's telling me what to do
okay I want to watch a movie can we just
can we pause this and I want to watch a
movie now so fast I mean this setup is
so much better than other VR headsets
okay look at the dot and tap your
fingers oh my goodness it's like it's
reading it it's reading my mind that is
unreal okay select all the circles
around oh my goodness this is so much
faster than a mouse I look and tap it's
I don't have to move my mouse around and
click okay guys I have to mention this
now that I have a fully white screen my
field of view is not as good as I
expected I have this whole ring around
me so my peripheral vision from this
point on I don't see
and I expected that to be better really
yeah now we have another issue here I
got my phone out and it is all blurry
just like with most cameras you have a
Minal focusing distance so right over
here it's sharp but it's still fuzzy to
read the text but if I want to look at
something close up this is all blurry
now and holding something up my hands
are super blurry so you have to hold
stuff further away and even from this
distance right here my phone screen
looks like you're looking at a 720p
monitor
you can read it but it's not great so
for once camera Tech is actually behind
the display Tech now raise your eyebrows
Close Your Eyes For a
Moment capture complete bro I could see
your eyes dude how's it look dude it
looks so crazy because it actually
matches up the depth of your eyes I can
now see myself too I look a little weird
time to log
in all right guys we are all set up and
we have some screen recording for for
you guys so you can do stuff like this
infinite glitch right there and now you
guys could see the quality and it is not
as good as we saw in the video now it
does depend on your lighting uh but
right now it doesn't look great and of
course it's camera so if I look at our
studio light everything gets dark we
have this exposure change and with field
of view right now I see viem right now I
don't and normally even like this i' see
them in my peripheral vision but you
don't have that range now you guys also
might be seeing some shaky video we'll
try to stabilize it but in my headset it
is much smoother than what you guys saw
online and the thing that shocked me the
most is this how quickly I can control
stuff with my eyes way faster than a
mouse it is insane and now let's go to I
believe Hawaii so let me grab this oh my
goodness wow okay I see the table I mean
the quality of the digital world is way
better than and the pass through because
the screens are insane VI I see you
right now you just popped up because I
could tell there's a human there that is
incredible let me try to go ahead and
blend this in all the way oh my goodness
I still see you which I think I could
turn off that feature okay guys this
destroys the quest this is what I've
always wanted when I put on VR headsets
the biggest issue was just the quality
and man I still still see my hands and
actually there's a little ghosting you
guys see that right here it's trying to
blend it together so that's not perfect
but oh my goodness and now let's go
ahead and blend it out you go the
opposite way okay man that is just as
good as in the video that requires some
killer processing wow now I actually
recorded one spatial video to get ready
for this my son figured out this trick
so let's see if it's actually worth
recording recording
this okay guys that looks 3D we have a
messy background there let me make this
full
screen okay yeah the quality is not as
good as 4K iPhone
footage but it literally looks like I'm
standing here and seeing everything pop
in 3D you probably won't see it online
through the 2D video but the spatial
video is great now I typically don't
record Panorama so I don't have a lot of
them but opening this up and just
scrolling it is so smooth and then just
selecting one of these Let's Go full
screen man I think I'm going to start
recording a lot more panoramas and now
we have to do a speaker test
unfortunately there's no YouTube app but
this guy created this Juno for YouTube
we're going to check that out we're
going to buy it for five bucks bam Apple
makes it so easy to spend money on this
WOW guys the app downloaded installed
almost instantly now we have this man so
smooth that is just insane you have to
go and try this thing out and check out
this I'm going to move this close to me
further look how easy and fast this is
and the crazy thing is I'm going to
place it here and I can literally walk
around right now bu what are you looking
at the camera it stays here perfectly in
place I can turn around it still knows
exactly where this is that is crazy all
right let's do our speaker test okay
let's turn this
[Music]
up I don't know if you guys can hear
that guys we have spatial audio Apple's
been working on this Tech forever
probably for this sound quality is
really good but I'm having a hard time
hearing you the base is not insane
but it sounds way better than the quest
now one thing that I discovered is that
the battery will actually accept up to
55 Watts where they only give you a 30
watt charger in the box so keep that in
mind if you want to fast charge and now
what I am really curious about and what
I feel like my use case is going to be
is connecting to my Mac so we see that
little popup let me go ahead and hit
connect I'm also um screen mirroring to
another laptop for the screen recording
and it's is doing both of these and Bam
guys there is my display and I have to
be honest with you guys it looks better
than I expected it legit looks like 4K
quality but the size of this thing is
maybe sitting next to like a 50-in
display um at least 45 way bigger than
like a 32 so if you had a 32in 4K it
would look worse than this so that is
really impr impressive now I have Final
Cut opened up right here let's hit
play now I'm not really sure how I can
switch it to have the audio to the
headset there but here is my
program I'm using my Mac for the
keyboard for the
mouse let's see if we have delay okay
look at that all that processing is
being done four times speed on my Mac
and it actually is really quick and as
far as the quality being able to read
everything it looks really good I can
legitimately see myself being able to
edit with no issues with really high
quality that is awesome and of course I
can move it to the side then I can open
up my app screen and now let's go ahead
and open up Safari I have Safari right
here I can move it over wow that's a
massive screen and I have my MacBook
let's just go ahead and make this a
little smaller look how easy it is to do
this I'll bring it closer to myself
right behind that can set this up right
here and the cool thing is I'm using my
MacBook right now to scroll in an app
that's being ran on division Pro typing
all without doing a bunch of extra stuff
there's some really ugly typing let's go
ahead and grab something else let's do
music I can grab this move it up here in
the back if I need to look up and change
something really
quick bam now that is really cool and
check this out guys I have apps behind
apps I have full
transparency I can set this up here now
I look at this application bam I still
have that in the background I can look
over switch back and forth that quick I
can see this go to my music go back go
to that look how insanely fast this is
it is just insane even with all of these
layers and another crazy thing is I've
been wearing this for almost 3 hours and
I went from about 76% battery life down
to
20% and that was close to 3 hours I have
it plugged in right now so the battery
life is better than I expected and as
far as comfort right now 3 hours wearing
it I'm feeling a little bit of pressure
right here and I'm wearing this band not
the one that goes over and I did tighten
it down quite a bit but I'm not having
any issues with the weight on my face so
that is also better than expected but I
want to tell you guys that I'm going to
make a video wearing this thing for a
full 8 hour work day without taking it
off so if you guys want to see that make
sure you click that Circle above let me
finally take this off dang man this is
crazy click it yeah it's different check
out one of those videos right over there
this been Max and I'll see you in the
next
[Music]
one